it's time for et social study a quick
update of what the stars are posting
online Selena Gomez lobs off her locks
hairstylist Marissa Moreno shared the
photo of selena's new due to Instagram
Cindy Crawford is fresh-faced and
flawless while taking in the sunlight
Jill Dillard of the Duggar family poses
with her growing baby bump Britney
Spears shares this shirtless pic of her
rumoured beau Sam mascari and days after
the birth of her son gray Douglas stupor
Molly Sims is sharing sweet family
photos of her tribe of five brother and
sister pitching in to help I think I
killed her sarah michelle gellar caught
dead working out with shannen doherty
she captioned the post the Slayer and
the cancer slayer sarah michelle gellar
being supportive through thick and thin
but sara had a scary incident the night
before when she had to take one of her
children to the ER for the very first
time she and Freddie Prinze juniors
four-year-old son Rocky was admitted for
an apparent nasty virus Sarah wrote of
the incident watching your child not be
able to breathe is the most helpless I
have ever felt
you